Speaker 1: We have now for several weeks been
covering. We could call it a rupture. We could
call it a crack, a crevasse, maybe between radical
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
and radical Republican Congresswoman Lauren
Boebert or Boebert. As Roxana likes to call her,
the divide is deepening. Take a look at this.
Unhinged is the word that Lauren Boebert is now
using to describe Marjorie Taylor GREENE. There is
a good Associated Press article. Boebert backers
urge her to tone down the nasty rhetoric. But
when you do a search for unhinged, you see
Boebert saying the following. I have been asked
to explain Marjorie Taylor Greene's beliefs on
Jewish space lasers or why she showed up to
a white supremacist conference. I'm just not
going to go there, Boebert said over the phone
as she wrote in a car winding through the high
canyons near her hometown of silt before the
speakership vote. She wants to say all these
things and seem unhinged on Twitter. So be it.
So be it. So then we hear from Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE And Marjorie Taylor. GREENE says
that Lauren Boebert approach to selecting
a speaker isn't serious. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: I think the American people,
no matter how you vote, are sick and tired of
drama. And this is nothing but drama. We're on
multiple days now with multiple candidates from
this group. So I'm not sure how Lauren Boebert on
one hand can demand so much out of Kevin McCarthy.
Oh, then demand nothing out of someone else and
be willing to vote for them to be speaker. That's
not serious. I don't think that's leadership. And
I really see it as more obstruction than progress.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is absolutely fascinating.
I know that many, many people, sadly, even in
my audience, are using the sort of misogynistic
term cat fight to describe this. Oh, it's a cat
fight. Well, this is actually a really interesting
political riff that I'm going to tell you why.
Before this rift, the Republican Party had MAGA
and they had non MAGA. They had the pro-Trump
Republican Party and the anti-Trump Republican
Party. So you had very, very sort of neatly
defined for the most part on one side, Mitt
Romney, Adam Kinzinger, Liz Cheney, the anti-Trump
people. And then you had MAGA. And Lauren Boebert
was part of MAGA and Marjorie Taylor GREENE
was part of MAGA. What you are seeing now is an
intra MAGA civil war. You still have Mitt Romney,
right? And Mitt Romney is not part of this boebert
thing and Mitt Romney is not part of this Marjorie
Taylor GREENE thing. Now he's also in the Senate,
so he doesn't vote for the speaker. And in that
sense, he's also separate. But now you see of a
subsequent division happening within MAGA. And
what's going on is that there are basically two
bets that you can make. And Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is making one bet. And Lauren Boebert is making
a different bet. And it could be entertaining in
the short run, but very consequential in the long
term for what happens with the Trump movement and
whether there is a Trump movement going forward.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE who was, you know. Q And
on follower, promoting violence, Jewish space,
lasers, all this different stuff, she has started
to reorient herself as a voice of reason within
the Republican Party. She is presumably going to
get committee assignments back with Kevin McCarthy
as Speaker of the House. She is now becoming
part of the establishment MAGA side. She's still
a Trump supporter, but she's probably realizing
that Trump's power is diminishing to some degree.
She wants to transform herself politically.
She's making the bet of, I'm going to ease up
a little bit on MAGA. I support Trump, but I'm
part of this other contingent. Lauren Boebert,
on the other hand, is going full in with We are
the defectors. We know what's really good for the
country. These people, like GREENE and others,
they might say they support the ultra MAGA wing,
but when it came down to it, they acquiesced, or
maybe even they gleefully went over to feeling
like we're now in power. We are now the big the
big boys and girls or whatever you want to say.
One of the really great things about Boebert
targeting GREENE is it's going to pull GREENE
back into the mud so she can't wipe herself off
and say, I'm with McCarthy now. You know, I'm a
you know, in the Mafia, you might say I'm now a
made man. You know, I'm in a different category
at this point. He's a friend of ours rather
than just a friend of mine. You know, if you've
read books about the Mafia, some of those terms
make sense. Marge wanted to sort of be the rat
fleeing the sinking ship after the Trump. Riots
failed on January 6th and the red wave failed
to materialize. And then Republicans argued with
these 20 or so of them resisting and resisting.
She saw the opportunity to flee the sinking ship.
But Bow Bear is trying to pull her back in. And
it's all good for the left in the sense that
the more fractured this movement is, I believe,
the better it is for the Democratic Party. If
you disagree with me, let me know. One of our
sponsors today is Xypex nicotine toothpicks. Xypex
brings you a convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and the vapor clouds, the ashtrays, the
thing in your lip that people can see. I've seen
that around. This is an easier and less messy way
to curb the cravings. And you can use xypex just
about anywhere. Xypex is available in six flavors
with two or three mg strength. The nicotine and
the flavor are long lasting and Xypex has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and they are
bad habits. Xypex toothpicks are FDA registered.
Their customer service is second to none. It is
one of the most cost effective alternatives. Also,
check out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks. See
for yourself why so many people have switched to
Xypex toothpicks. You can only get xypex online.
Go to Xypex toothpick scum and get 10% off
with the code Packman. The link is down below.